From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. A couple of years ago, one of our producers put together this story that just got too big for our show. It couldn't be contained in an hour or two hours. And so it spun out into its own podcast series called The Retrievals. It was a big hit. Maybe you heard it. Our coworkers at Serial at The New York Times produced it.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。几年前，我们的一位制作人整理了这个故事，由于内容太丰富，以至于我们的节目无法容纳。它无法被限制在一两个小时内。因此，它衍生出了自己的播客系列，名为《取回者》（The Retrievals）。它非常受欢迎。也许你听过。我们的同事，《纽约时报》的Serial制作了这个节目。
Anyway, now that producer, Susan Burton, is back with a story that is just as compelling. And they have released it as season two of The Retrievals. At first, I heard drafts of this months ago. And I am very excited that we can present one of the episodes for you today. I have to say, one of the things that I really like about this story is that by the end, it turns out to be surprisingly hopeful.
总之，现在那位制作人苏珊·伯顿带着一个同样引人入胜的故事回归了。他们将其作为《取回者》的第二季发布。起初，我在几个月前就听过草稿。我非常激动今天能为大家呈现其中一集。我必须说，我非常喜欢这个故事的一点是，到最后，它竟然出奇地充满希望。
She also invented this way to tell a radio story I have never heard anybody try. I hope you like it. I think you'll like it. The story takes place in a hospital's labor and delivery unit. And there's some description in here of medical procedures. And things don't go well. Just a heads-up. Here's Susan.
她还发明了一种我从未听说过有人尝试过的广播故事讲述方式。我希望你喜欢它。我想你会喜欢的。这个故事发生在一所医院的劳产科病房。其中包含一些对医疗程序的描述。而且事情进展得并不顺利。先预警一下。这是苏珊。
6:00 AM in Chicago. Of course, the shot starts at the lake. Camera pans over the water and the magnificent buildings rise from the shoreline, twinkling in the dawn light. We continue across the city, still bird's-eye view, over the grid, over the elevated tracks and wide highways, coming to rest in a western suburb.
芝加哥时间上午6点。当然，镜头从湖边开始。摄像机掠过水面，壮丽的建筑从岸边升起，在黎明的光线下闪烁。我们继续穿过城市，依然是鸟瞰视角，掠过街道网格，掠过高架铁轨和宽阔的高速公路，最终停在西郊。
Drop down to a brick bungalow where, inside, a woman, late 30s, moves softly past the bedrooms where her children sleep and steps out the front door to meet the morning. Wind chill of 20 below. She hurries to a minivan. And as she pulls away from the curb, we see the streets frosted with salt, the moon shining high and hard. And we see her work ID where she keeps it on the center console. The words "BOARD CERTIFIED RN" and her name in all caps.
镜头下降到一栋红砖平房，屋内，一位30多岁的女性轻轻走过孩子们熟睡的卧室，走出前门迎接清晨。风寒指数零下20度。她匆忙走向一辆小型货车。当她从路边驶离时，我们看到街道上结着霜，月亮又高又亮。我们看到她放在中央控制台上的工作证。上面写着“委员会认证注册护士”，以及她的大写姓名。
This is Mindy Figueroa. Mindy says she was made to be a nurse.
这就是明迪·菲格罗亚。明迪说她天生就是做护士的料。
I think I was just born to be in healthcare. Like, as a kid, my sister would find all the dolls and the ballet slippers at the Dollar Tree, like, section. But I always got the doctor kit, the stethoscope, the little syringe. Always, always, always. So it was just always a thing.
我觉得我生来就是做医疗行业的。就像小时候，我姐姐会在一元店找到所有的玩偶和芭蕾舞鞋，但我总是拿医生套装、听诊器、小注射器。总是，总是，总是。所以这对我来说一直是一件很自然的事。
Mindy was the first one in her family to go to college. Her parents came to this country undocumented, from Mexico, worked factory jobs, earned citizenship. Mindy paid her way through school, got her degree, started out at a small hospital, and after a few years, transferred up to a big one-- UI Health at the University of Illinois at Chicago.
明迪是她家里第一个上大学的人。她的父母从墨西哥非法移民到这个国家，做着工厂的工作，后来获得了公民身份。明迪靠自己打工付学费读完了书，拿到了学位，起初在一家小医院工作，几年后调到了一家大医院——伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校（UIC）的UIC Health。
She works on the labor and delivery floor, with patients about to have babies.
她在劳产科工作，照顾即将分娩的病人。
I've been told many, many times that as soon as I walk in the room, they know I like my job. And I love coming to work. And I feel like they feel that. So I walk in a room and good morning, my name is Mindy. I will be here until 7:00 PM.
我被告知过很多很多次，我一走进房间，她们就知道我喜欢我的工作。而且我热爱上班。我觉得她们能感受到这一点。所以我走进房间就会说，早上好，我叫明迪。我会一直在这儿待到晚上7点。
We watch this happen, Mindy stepping cheerfully into a labor room, her face framed by two neat braids. And then we carousel through shots of Mindy at work-- Mindy strapping a fetal monitor to a patient's belly, Mindy at the nursing station holding a plastic pillow up like show and tell, her colleagues doubled over in laughter, Mindy, her face grave, bursting through the door of the OR.
我们看着这一切发生，明迪愉快地走进待产室，她的脸被两根整齐的辫子衬托着。然后我们闪回到明迪工作的镜头——明迪给病人的腹部绑上胎儿监护仪，明迪在护士站举起一个塑料枕头展示，同事们笑得直不起腰，明迪表情严肃地冲进手术室。
Mindy loves the intimacy of labor and delivery. And that adrenaline, that switch from, it's calm to now it's time to run.
明迪热爱分娩过程的亲密感。还有那种肾上腺素，那种从平静到必须立刻行动的切换。
And also, I mean, I just like blood, in general. [LAUGHS]
而且，我也很喜欢血，总的来说。[笑]
You do?
真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Do you mean literally, you like blood?
你是说真的喜欢血吗？
Yes. And everyone on the unit knows it. If there is a hemorrhage, if there is heavy bleeding, they know I am the person. I like to weigh it. I like to quantify the blood. I like to clean it up. Blood clots coming out of after delivery and we're pushing on their belly and it's almost like popping a pimple. Like, OK, let's get it out of there to prevent more bleeding.
是的。科室里的每个人都知道这一点。如果有大出血，如果有严重的流血，他们知道我就是那个人。我喜欢称量它。我喜欢量化出血量。我喜欢清理它。分娩后血块出来，我们按压她们的肚子，感觉就像挤粉刺一样。就像，好吧，我们把它排出来以防止进一步出血。
And I feel like I'm really good at recognizing when we're trending towards too much blood. Because I am actually watching. I watch every birth. I watch every C-section. Like, I don't sit and chart. As soon as the incision starts, I watch it. Because it's just intriguing to me. I've been doing this for 14 years. And it still amazes me that there's an incision on an abdomen, but there's a baby there. So I watch every delivery.
我觉得我非常擅长识别我们是否正趋向于出血过多。因为我确实在看。我看每一次出生。我看每一次剖腹产。我不只是坐着写病历。切口一开始，我就盯着看。因为它对我来说太引人入胜了。我已经做了14年了。腹部开了一个口，里面却有一个婴儿，这依然让我感到惊奇。所以我看每一次分娩。
This story is going to be about one of those deliveries that Mindy watched, one that changed things for her and for her hospital. There are more than 2,000 deliveries a year at UIC. It's a public hospital, not a fancy one. And it's located right in the middle of the city, in the medical district.
这个故事将讲述明迪目睹的其中一次分娩，那次经历改变了她和她的医院。UIC每年有超过2000次分娩。这是一家公立医院，不是什么高级医院。它位于城市中心，在医疗区。
Establishing shot of the hulking building, dawn breaking open the sky above. A humble hospital in Chicago, a hard-working nurse, a delivery with stakes-- how could we not tell this like a medical drama? A medical drama, its emphasis is on the world inside the hospital, on the heart and the heroism of the people who work there, on their relationships with one another, on how their interactions with patients are shaped by their own stories.
全景镜头对准那座笨重的建筑，黎明照亮了天空。芝加哥的一家简朴医院，一位勤奋的护士，一场关系重大的分娩——我们怎么能不把它拍成一部医疗剧呢？一部医疗剧，重点在于医院内部的世界，在于在那里工作的人们的心灵和英雄主义，在于他们彼此的关系，在于他们与病人的互动如何受他们自身故事的影响。
But what happens in a hospital also reverberates outside. And on this show, we're going to see that too. Because this delivery that Mindy watches, it doesn't just change things at UIC. It could change things for the entire country.
但医院里发生的事情也会在外部产生影响。在这个节目中，我们也会看到这一点。因为明迪目睹的这场分娩，不仅改变了UIC的事情。它可能会改变整个国家。
And now let's pull back, get the whole hospital in the frame, and end the opening credit sequence with this image, this boxy building on the subzero morning. But we know that behind that imposing facade, it's warm. We're already invested in the human drama inside. Black screen.
现在让我们拉远镜头，把整个医院纳入画面，用这个在零度清晨的方块建筑影像结束片头序列。但我们知道，在那宏伟的外表下，里面很温暖。我们已经被内部的人性故事所吸引。黑屏。
Susan Burton's story continues. Stay with us.
苏珊·伯顿的故事继续。请留步。
It's This American Life. Susan Burton picks up where she left off.
这里是《美国生活》。苏珊·伯顿从上次结束的地方继续。
The action of the episode begins with Mindy in a nearly empty elevator. Closer to 7:00 AM, change of shift, you can barely fit, it's sardines. But Mindy's early today. She's almost always early. She's the one who will have cleaned the break room by the time her coworkers arrive.
这一集的情节开始于一个几乎空无一人的电梯里的明迪。快到早上7点，换班时，电梯里挤得像沙丁鱼。但明迪今天来早了。她几乎总是很早。她是那种在同事到达之前就把休息室打扫干净的人。
At UIC, your coworkers have your back. Mindy could say this about all of the nurses on her crew. One of those nurses is Clara Hochhauser. We see her emerging from the locker room in gray scrubs and a scrub coat. Not everyone wears a scrub coat, but Clara does because it has better pockets and because it covers her tattoos.
在UIC，同事就是你的后盾。明迪对她组里的所有护士都可以这么说。其中一位护士是克拉拉·霍克豪瑟。我们看到她穿着灰色刷手服和刷手外套从更衣室出来。并不是每个人都穿刷手外套，但克拉拉穿是因为它有更好的口袋，而且能遮住她的纹身。
Clara has large, wise eyes, as if she sees more than other people. She's a natural at nursing, but it wasn't obvious that it was where she would wind up.
克拉拉有着大而睿智的眼睛，仿佛她能看到比别人更多的东西。她天生就是做护士的料，但这并不是她最终会从事的行业，起初并不明显。
I am, like, a high school dropout. I really did not do well with school. And long story short, I just was like, never mind, I'll get my GED. And I started working. And I worked in a coffee shop.
我，算是高中辍学。我在学校表现真的很不好。长话短说，我当时就想，算了吧，我拿个同等学力证书就行。于是我开始工作。我在一家咖啡店工作。
One day, Clara got a massage, and then she became a massage therapist. And she found the clients she liked best were the pregnant clients. So then she decided to become a midwife. But after finishing her degree, she just wanted to start working. And as a nurse, she could do that sooner. She started as a mother-baby nurse and eventually switched to labor and delivery.
有一天，克拉拉做了按摩，后来她成了按摩治疗师。她发现她最喜欢的客户是孕妇。于是她决定成为一名助产士。但在完成学位后，她只想开始工作。作为一名护士，她可以更快地做到这一点。她起初是一名母婴护士，后来转到了劳产科。
She never thought she would have her own kids.
她从没想过自己会有孩子。
I definitely never planned on having children. I definitely always felt like, ooh, emotionally, a little dysfunctional family.
我绝对从来没打算要孩子。我绝对一直觉得，噢，在情感上，我家有点功能失调。
Yeah.
是的。
I identified, like, purely as a lesbian. I was not able to conceptualize what it meant to be bisexual. That wasn't an option. It's either you were gay or you weren't gay, you know?
我纯粹认同自己是女同性恋。我无法概念化双性恋意味着什么。那不是一个选项。你要么是同性恋，要么不是，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And not that you can't have babies with women. But just all the things, I just thought, no, no, no, no, I love little babies, but I do not want to be a parent.
并不是说你不能和女性生孩子。但种种原因，我当时就想，不不不，我喜欢小宝宝，但我不想成为家长。
And then Clara got divorced from her wife. She met a guy. They got married. Suddenly, Clara understood she didn't have to be, as she puts it, a perfect, magical, special person to have children. She was 40. With her husband, Clay, she did IVF, and soon she was pregnant with twins.
后来克拉拉和她的妻子离婚了。她遇到了一个男人。他们结婚了。突然，克拉拉明白了她不必像她说的那样，是一个完美、神奇、特别的人才能生孩子。她40岁了。她和丈夫克莱做了试管婴儿（IVF），不久后她就怀上了双胞胎。
I was incredibly excited and could not believe that two embryos took when-- you know?
我非常兴奋，简直不敢相信两个胚胎都着床了，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It just all seemed surreal. Like, I can't believe it worked the very first transfer. But I, of course, was really nervous about the outcome because I see firsthand all the time the ways in which pregnancies can go sideways. And there are no guarantees that anybody goes home with a baby at the end. So it was just like another layer of worry.
这一切看起来太超现实了。就像，我不敢相信第一次移植就成功了。但我当然对结果非常紧张，因为我总是第一手看到怀孕可能出错的种种方式。而且没有任何保证说明最后每个人都能带着孩子回家。所以那只是又多了一层担忧。
Yeah.
是的。
Clara would go home with her babies. That's not where this story is going. She would also be delivering at UIC herself. On a medical drama, when the healthcare provider becomes the patient, it's a twist. But this isn't a twist. It's our premise. We don't know how this matters yet, but it will. It matters that this patient is not a visitor, that she's not someone who leaves, but someone who stays.
克拉拉最后带着她的孩子回家了。这不是这个故事的方向。她自己也会在UIC分娩。在一部医疗剧中，当医护人员变成病人时，这是一个转折。但这并不是一个转折。这是我们的前提。我们还不知道这为何重要，但它会很重要。重要的是，这位病人不是访客，她不是那种会离开的人，而是会留下来的人。
A twin pregnancy at age 40-- there was definitely a chance that Clara would need a C-section, but she wanted to avoid it.
40岁的双胞胎妊娠，克拉拉确实有需要剖腹产的可能，但她想避免。
I wanted so badly to have a vaginal delivery. I did not want to have surgery. But because I was older, because I'm a bit fat, I just was like, oh god.
我非常渴望顺产。我不想做手术。但因为我年龄大了，因为我有点胖，我当时就想，天哪。
Clara also wanted to avoid delivering in the operating room. Typically, if you're having twins, you can labor in a labor room, but you have to deliver in the operating room, even if you're delivering vaginally. It's a safety thing, just be in the right room if something goes wrong. But Clara really did not want this.
克拉拉还想避免在手术室分娩。通常，如果你怀的是双胞胎，你可以在待产室待产，但你必须在手术室分娩，即使是顺产。这是一种安全措施，为了以防万一。但克拉拉真的不想这样。
But the idea of having to deliver in the operating room was horrifying to me. I was just terrified of the OR, more or less.
但必须在手术室分娩的想法让我感到恐惧。我基本上对手术室感到害怕。
How come?
为什么？
Um, delivering in the operating room always just seems so awful to me. I don't know. It's this really narrow, metal table.
嗯，在手术室分娩对我来说似乎太可怕了。我不知道。那是一张非常窄的金属桌子。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
You're flat on your back. You're not restrained, but where are you going to go? You've got an epidural. You're gonna be hooked up to more monitors. You know? Like, it takes away any of that just safety and autonomy, you know?
你平躺着。你没有被约束，但你又能去哪儿呢？你打了硬膜外麻醉。你会连接更多的监护仪。你知道吗？它剥夺了那种安全感和自主权，你明白吗？
Yeah.
是的。
One of the things Clara did want was for Mindy, her coworker, to take pictures of the birth.
克拉拉想要的一件事就是让她的同事明迪为分娩拍照。
So I have a side hustle, like a photography-- it's a hobby. But I take our coworker's birth pictures.
所以我有一份副业，摄影——这只是个爱好。但我拍我们同事的分娩照片。
Mindy's always taken pictures. Back in college with the little cameras you'd hang on your wrist. Eventually she got a camera with a big lens that attached and taught herself how to use it from YouTube.
明迪一直很喜欢拍照。在大学里带着挂在手腕上的小相机。最终她买了一台带有大镜头并能连接的相机，并从YouTube上自学了如何使用它。
And then one of my nursing friends was pregnant. And she's like, will you take some pictures of me pregnant? She's like, I don't like to go to places. And so I took a few of her and made them black and white. And they were exceptional. And I was like, huh.
然后我的一位护士朋友怀孕了。她说，你能给我拍些孕妇照吗？她说，我不喜欢去那些地方。于是我拍了几张她的，做成黑白的。照片非常出色。我就想，嗯。
And then when she had her baby, she's like, can you take pictures of my baby? And she paid me. And I was like, you don't have to pay me. But she paid me like $200. And I was like, [GASPS], that's a lot of money. Like, no, I'm not a professional. And it just took off from there.
后来她生完孩子，她说，你能给我的宝宝拍照吗？她付了我钱。我说，你不用付我钱。但她还是付了我大约200美元。我当时想，[喘息]，这可是很多钱。就像，不，我不是专业人士。然后它就这样开始了。
Yeah. Do you take, like if somebody's having a cesarean, would you take a picture of the surgical field?
是的。如果你拍剖腹产，你会拍手术区域吗？
Yes. Yeah. I'll take a picture of the bloody canister. And I do ask. I do ask how graphic I can get. Because I will literally take a picture of turd coming out, you know?
是的。是的。我会拍那个沾满血的罐子。我确实会问。我会问我可以拍到什么程度。因为我真的会拍那种屎出来的照片，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I will photograph it all because I am not squeamish. But there's people who are like, that's too much. Or if they're doing skin to skin and it's a beautiful photo, I make sure I cover the nipple so that they can use that photo. Yeah, I just gauge who they are. How graphic are we doing? And I think Clara was one of those who's like, let's do it all.
我会把一切都拍下来，因为我不晕血。但有些人会觉得，那太过了。或者如果她们在做皮肤接触，那是一张漂亮的照片，我会确保遮住乳头，这样她们就可以用那张照片。是的，我只是评估她们是谁。我们要拍到什么程度？我觉得克拉拉就是那种说，全都拍下来吧的人。
On April 19, 2022, Clara arrived at the hospital for a scheduled induction, which is when you get drugs to start your labor. Now, we flashback to see her on that day. She and her husband, Clay, are crossing the street from the staff garage.
2022年4月19日，克拉拉到达医院进行预定的引产，就是当你注射药物开始分娩时。现在，我们回到那一天。她和她的丈夫克莱正从员工停车场过马路。
Clara's purposeful, leading the way. Clay's just passed the bar, is going into criminal defense, did an internship advocating for victims of police brutality. It matters that you know something about Clay so that he's a little more than just the cut-out husband, more than just the husband watching the main event.
克拉拉目标明确，走在前面。克莱刚刚通过律师资格考试，准备从事刑事辩护工作，做过为警察暴行受害者辩护的实习。了解克莱的一些情况很重要，这样他不仅仅是一个背景丈夫，不仅仅是一个观看主要事件的丈夫。
At the employee entrance, Clara badges in.
在员工入口处，克拉拉刷卡进入。
I was coming in. I was scheduled for an evening induction. And so I thought, yeah, I like that. I like those evening inductions. So I'll come in at night after dinner. And I'll get the initial stuff and then go from there.
我进来了。我预定了晚上的引产。所以我心想，耶，我喜欢那个。我喜欢那些晚上的引产。所以我会在晚饭后晚上过来。我会做初步的准备，然后从那里开始。
On the fourth floor, Clara enters her labor room, Room 5, the best one. That's where they try to put you if you're a staff member. Her co-workers have decorated it for her. She changes into a gown, climbs into bed. Clay sets a Bluetooth Speaker on the windowsill, opens his phone, starts the playlist. "Push It," it's on everyone's playlist. The Beach Boys' "Don't Worry Baby."
在四楼，克拉拉进入了她的待产室，5号房，最好的房间。如果你是员工，他们会尽量安排你住那里。她的同事们为她装饰了房间。她换上病号服，爬上床。克莱把蓝牙音箱放在窗台上，打开手机，开始播放列表。《Push It》，每个人的播放列表里都有。海滩男孩的《Don't Worry Baby》。
And so far, Clara's not worried. Even when she receives the drugs to start her labor, everything feels surprisingly OK. By around lunchtime the next day, she's in some pain from her contractions and is debating whether it's time to go for an epidural.
到目前为止，克拉拉并不担心。即使在她接受了引产药物后，一切感觉都出奇地好。第二天午饭左右，她因为宫缩感到了一些疼痛，并正在纠结是否该打硬膜外麻醉了。
And I felt really, really neurotic about it. Not wanting to get it too soon because I wanted to be able to stay upright and keep moving. But you don't want to wait too long because then you're dying in pain.
我对此感到非常神经质。不想太早打，因为我想保持直立并继续走动。但你也不想等太久，那样你会在疼痛中死去。
Yeah.
是的。
One of my coworkers, a midwife, came in and talked with me and was just like, all right, Clara, it's fine. Just get it. If you're ready, you can get it. It's nothing to get perfect here. If you want it and you know you want it, just do it. So Heather did my epidural.
我的一位助产士同事进来看我，跟我说，好了，克拉拉，没关系。就打吧。如果你准备好了，你就可以打。这里没什么好追求完美的。如果你想要，并且你知道你想要，就做吧。所以希瑟帮我打了硬膜外麻醉。
Heather Nixon, the head of obstetric anesthesia at UIC, charismatic, assertive, boss lady, but not bossy. Let's actually meet Heather on the way into the room. Let's watch her leaving her office downstairs on the anesthesia floor.
希瑟·尼克松，UIC产科麻醉主管，有魅力，果断，老板派头，但不霸道。让我们在去房间的路上见见希瑟。让我们看看她离开楼下麻醉科办公室。
Heather's office-- mini fridge, on top of it a framed photo of four women dressed up for girls' night, a black leather couch with a hot pink pillow where lots of times Heather spends the night. Heather is 51, with two daughters in college. But she's the one with the energy of a college kid-- can sleep anywhere, pop up bright-eyed at weird hours.
希瑟的办公室——小冰箱，上面放着一张四个女孩晚上聚会的合影，一张黑色皮沙发，上面有一个热粉色的枕头，希瑟经常在那里过夜。希瑟51岁，两个女儿都在上大学。但她有着大学生的活力——随处能睡，在奇怪的时间也能精神奕奕地出现。
My residents actually did a skit once with me. They do the end of the year roast of the attendings. And it was a skit where it was like 3:00 in the morning and they kept answering the phone. And I was like, hey, it's Nixon from anesthesia. And they're like, we have no idea how you're always awake. You're always like, let's talk about stuff at like 3:00 in the morning. I'm like, I don't know.
我的住院医生其实有一次跟我演过一个小品。他们会在年底烤这些主治医生。那是一个小品，就像凌晨3点，他们不停地接电话。我说，嘿，我是麻醉科的尼克松。他们说，我们真不知道你怎么总是醒着。你总是说，嘿，凌晨3点咱们来讨论些事情。我说，我不知道。
Heather has lived in Chicago for 30 years, came to the city straight after finishing college. She knew she wanted to be a doctor, but she had to pay off student loans first. So she worked as a shot girl in a bar off Rush Street, T-shirt tied up, abdomen showing.
希瑟在芝加哥住了30年，大学一毕业就来到了这座城市。她知道她想成为一名医生，但她必须先还清学生贷款。所以她在拉什街附近的一家酒吧当过射击酒侍，T恤系着，露出腹部。
Anesthesia itself came as a surprise to Heather. It wasn't a specialty she'd ever thought she'd want to do. But she had a mentor who made her fall in love with it. This is the case for a lot of anesthesiologists. There's a common misconception that this is the doctor who just puts you to sleep. But there's a lot more to it than that. The surgeon has their head down in the surgical field. The anesthesiologist is watching over all of you.
麻醉本身对希瑟来说是个意外。这不是她曾想过的专科。但她有一位导师让她爱上了它。很多麻醉师都是这种情况。有一个常见的误解，认为这只是那个让你睡觉的医生。但这不仅仅如此。外科医生低着头在手术区域忙碌。麻醉师在照看你的全身。
When Heather discovered the subspecialty of obstetric anesthesia, she had a feeling like, OB, this is my tribe. These are my people.
当希瑟发现产科麻醉这个亚专科时，她有一种感觉，产科，这是我的部落。这就是我的人。
I think you'll find two types of anesthesiologists-- the ones who are the introverts who like to hide behind the drapes with asleep patients and then there's the type that really like to engage with their patients. And those are maybe the tribe of OB anesthesiologists, the ones who want to be there talking to their patients.
我觉得你会发现两种类型的麻醉师——那些喜欢躲在帘子后面照顾熟睡病人的内向者，还有那种真正喜欢与病人交流的类型。而那些可能就是产科麻醉师的部落，那些想要在那里与病人交谈的人。
Many OB anesthesiologists proudly identify the same way. They like awake patients, not sleeping patients. Now we catch back up to the action. And we see Heather enter Clara's room and begin arranging her equipment on a tray. Clara sits erect on the bed, waiting, bed pumped up high, her feet dangling.
许多产科麻醉师自豪地以同样的方式认同。他们喜欢清醒的病人，而不是熟睡的病人。现在我们回到剧情。我们看到希瑟走进克拉拉的房间，开始在托盘上整理她的设备。克拉拉直立在床上等待，床泵得很高，脚垂着。
She'd asked for Heather to do her epidural like, hey, Nixon you gonna be around? Heather was happy to do it. She does this for all her providers delivering if she can. Not that a resident couldn't do it, but you want to take ownership if, god forbid, something goes wrong. Close on Heather's gloved fingers touching Clara's spine.
她要求希瑟帮她打硬膜外麻醉，就像，嘿，尼克松你在吗？希瑟很乐意这样做。如果可以的话，她会对所有分娩的医护人员这样做。不是说住院医生不能做，但你想要承担责任，万一出事了怎么办。特写希瑟戴着手套的手指触碰克拉拉的脊椎。
Now we're going to watch Heather actually do this procedure. We're going to be talking a lot about procedures on this show, and viewers need to be grounded in them. And does anyone really know what an epidural is, besides the thing you can get for pain when you're having a baby?
现在我们要看希瑟实际执行这个程序。我们要在这个节目中谈论很多程序，观众需要了解它们。除了生孩子时可以用来止痛的东西之外，还有谁真正知道什么是硬膜外麻醉吗？
Now we see Clara take an anxious peek over her shoulder and Heather telling her, no, no, I'll talk you through it. You'd think nurses and OBs, they'd be the most relaxed about the epidural, but they're just as nervous as anyone. From her tray, Heather picks up something that looks like a swizzle stick, like what you use to stir a cocktail.
现在我们看到克拉拉焦虑地回头看了一眼，希瑟告诉她，不不，我会引导你完成它的。你以为护士和产科医生会对硬膜外麻醉最放松，但她们和任何人一样紧张。希瑟从她的托盘上拿起了一个看起来像搅拌棒的东西，就像你用来搅拌鸡尾酒的那种。
This is actually a large, hollow needle, and its placement in Clara's back, this might cause someone to turn from the screen for just a second. So I'll tell you what Heather's doing. She's inching that needle into Clara's back a little deeper, a little more, until the tip enters what's called the epidural space. Heather finds that space by feel. There's a ligament she's looking for.
这实际上是一根粗大的空心针，它在克拉拉背部的放置，可能会让观众转头一会儿。所以我告诉你希瑟在做什么。她正一点一点地把那根针推入克拉拉的背部，直到针尖进入所谓的硬膜外腔。希瑟通过感觉找到那个空间。她正在寻找一根韧带。
And not everyone's ligament feels the same. Some of them feel really rubbery. Some of them feel kind of like crackly or poppily, you know, popping. Some of them feel kind of really, like, gentle, like almost when you pass through, you're like, oh, something's different, but I'm just going to stop there.
并不是每个人的韧带感觉都一样。有些感觉真的很橡胶感。有些感觉像咔哒声或波普声，你知道，那种破裂声。有些感觉非常温柔，当你穿过它时，你会觉得，噢，有些不同，但我就在这儿停下。
Now, Heather threads a thin plastic tube, a catheter, you know this word, through the large, hollow needle until the plastic tube is inside the epidural space as well. We could go one level deeper with the science, explain that the epidural space is not really a space at all, just potential space. But I won't get into this. Just nod to it so that doctors watching can be like, on this show, they know what they're talking about.
现在，希瑟通过粗大的空心针穿过一根细细的塑料管，导管，你知道这个词，直到塑料管也进入了硬膜外腔。我们本可以再深入一层科学层面，解释硬膜外腔并不是真正的空间，只是潜在空间。但我不会深入这一点。只是点到为止，这样观看的医生会觉得，在这个节目中，他们知道自己在说什么。
Now, Heather slides the needle off the plastic tube, which stays in Clara's back. Anesthetic drugs will be delivered through the tube, bathing the nerves near her spinal cord. Clara is relieved when the procedure is over.
现在，希瑟把针从塑料管上滑走，塑料管留在克拉拉的背部。麻醉药物将通过管子输送，浸润脊髓附近的神经。当程序结束时，克拉拉感到如释重负。
Even though it wasn't like a painful needle or something like that, it was such a strange, unnerving feeling, that pressure in your spine or whatever. But I got it and it was fine. But then around dinner time, I think, was the first time that trouble started with my epidural, where I didn't really even understand what was happening because it was just in my vagina that I felt pain.
尽管它不像那种痛苦的针头或什么的，但脊柱里那种压力或其他什么的真是太奇怪、太令人不安的感觉了。但我打了，它很好。但后来在晚餐时间，我想，是第一次出问题，我的硬膜外麻醉出现了问题，我甚至都不明白发生了什么，因为我感到疼痛的地方就在我的阴道里。
So I wasn't really-- I wasn't aware of contractions. It was just all of a sudden, it felt like my vagina was just being shredded. I don't know. It literally felt like somebody had a steel toe boot and was just kicking around in there.
所以我并没有——我没有意识到宫缩。这只是突然间，感觉就像我的阴道正在被撕碎。我不知道。这真的感觉就像有人穿着钢头靴在里面乱踢。
Oh, geez.
噢，天哪。
Clara's epidural is topped up with more drugs. And that does the trick. She's more comfortable right away. A couple hours later, at 11 o'clock, Heather signs out to the anesthesiologist on the overnight shift and fills him in on Clara.
克拉拉的硬膜外麻醉又加了更多药。这马上就起作用了。她立刻舒服多了。几个小时后，在11点，希瑟把病人移交给了夜班的麻醉师，并向他介绍了克拉拉的情况。
When I was signing out, I was like, hey, this is the deal. It's working, blah, blah, blah. And so I didn't anticipate any problems when I left. Otherwise, I would have probably stayed. In hindsight, now, one of the things I'm always like, for my providers that I'm taking care of, I kind of just stay in the hospital. Because I just want to be the one who's there if anything happens.
当我移交时，我说，嘿，就是这样。它起作用了，巴拉巴拉。所以我离开时没预料到会有任何问题。否则，我可能就会留下来。回想起来，现在，我总是说的一件事是，对于我照顾的同事，我基本上就留在医院。因为我只想成为万一出事时在那儿的人。
We see Heather get in her car, drive away from the hospital.
我们看到希瑟上车，开车离开了医院。
Clara had been comfortable when Heather left. But several hours later, she's having the same pain again. And other things are going wrong, too. Her labor is stalling. Her blood sugar is climbing. So are the babies' heart rates. Clara knows she's headed for a C-section, but she requests one last half hour laboring on her hands and knees just to see if that will help.
希瑟离开时克拉拉很舒服。但几个小时后，她又有了同样的疼痛。还有其他事情也在出错。她的产程停滞了。她的血糖在升高。宝宝们的心率也是。克拉拉知道她要去剖腹产了，但她请求最后半小时尝试跪着产，看看是否有效。
Now we see the room, dark, except for the lights of the monitors, Clara on all fours in the hospital bed. Close of her forearms, we briefly glimpsed the tattoos. We remember for a moment that Clara has stripped a layer off for us. There's a lot of vulnerability in what she's allowing us to see. The only other person in the room is Clay.
现在我们看到房间，昏暗，除了监护仪的灯光，克拉拉跪在病床上。特写她的前臂，我们短暂瞥见了纹身。我们瞬间记起克拉拉为我们剥下了一层外壳。她允许我们看到的东西里有很多脆弱性。房间里唯一的另一个人是克莱。
That was another thing Clara had requested, just please, everyone clear out and give me one more try. But the try doesn't work, and there's no more time to waste. The nurses unplug Clara from her monitors and push her cumbersome bed down the hall to the OR.
这是克拉拉要求的另一件事，请，每个人都清空，让我再试一次。但尝试没有奏效，没有更多时间可以浪费了。护士们断开了克拉拉监护仪的连接，把她笨重的床沿着走廊推向手术室。
But I was like, OK, it's gonna be fine. It's gonna be fine. My babies are gonna be born.
但我当时想，没事的。没事的。我的宝宝们会出生的。
And yeah, she called me around 3:00 or 4:00 in the morning that they had decided to do a C-section.
是的，她在凌晨3点或4点左右给我打电话，说他们决定剖腹产了。
Mindy was at home, asleep, but she got right out of bed and grabbed her camera bag. We see her, strap over her shoulder, hurrying down the bungalow's front steps and into her minivan.
明迪在家睡觉，但她立刻起床拿起了她的相机包。我们看到她背着带子，匆忙跑下平房的前台阶，进入她的小货车。
So I raced over there. And it was a little bit of an urgent case, meaning it's not what we call a crash, like where we literally just rip cords out of the wall and run. It was like, all right, we're doing this now. Let's move. So I'm only 10 minutes away from the hospital when there's no traffic.
所以我冲向那里。这是一个稍微紧急的病例，意味着它不是我们所说的“冲刺”，就像那种我们直接把线从墙上扯下来跑的那种。这就像，好的，我们现在就做这个。动起来吧。所以当没有交通时，我离医院只有10分钟的路程。
So I raced over there. And I parked on the street because I'm like, it's an urgent case. I need to go because they might start before I get there. I even got a parking ticket that day. Because at night, you don't pay for the meters, but I was there so long that in the morning, they gave me a ticket. But, anyways.
所以我冲向那里。我把车停在街上，因为我想，这是一个紧急病例。我需要走，因为他们可能在我到之前就开始了。那天我还收到了停车罚单。因为在晚上，你不用付停车费，但我待得太久了，以至于早上他们给了我一张罚单。但是，不管怎样。
Up on the fourth floor, Mindy takes a plastic-wrapped surgical suit from a closet and pulls the coverall on over her clothes. Then she turns toward Clara's OR.
在四楼，明迪从衣柜里拿出一套塑料包装的手术服，把连体服套在衣服外面。然后她转向克拉拉的手术室。
And I walked in when she was on the operating room table. And I actually have a beautiful photo of her. She has not seen these photos-- or I gave them to her, but I don't think she's ever been able to look at them. But it's the door of the operating room halfway open. And she's laying there with her arms out, and she's looking at me smiling.
我走进手术室时，她还在手术台上。我确实有一张她的美丽照片。她没见过这些照片——或者我给了她，但我觉得她从来没能看它们。但那是手术室的门半开着。她躺在那儿，双臂张开，看着我微笑。
So then, when I got there and I took that picture, just her joy and I almost sensed relief. She knew I was there. And we are all either night shift nurses or day shift nurses. And even though we're all one team, there's more of a friendship and bond. Day shift nurses, we all know how we work. And night shift, we don't work with them ever. So we don't know how they roll.
所以，当我到那里拍下那张照片时，仅仅是她的喜悦，我甚至感到了解脱。她知道我在那儿。我们要么是夜班护士，要么是白班护士。尽管我们都是一个团队，但有一种更深的友谊和纽带。白班护士，我们都知道我们是怎么工作的。而夜班，我们从来不和他们一起工作。所以我们不知道他们的风格。
So I think that smile was like, I'm having my babies. You made it to take my pictures. You're here. You're one of me, one of our team. So yeah, and I, too, was like, yes, I'm here for you. And [SIGHS], this is why this case is so hard because I feel like I failed her 100%.
所以我认为那个微笑就像是，我要生孩子了。你赶来拍我的照片了。你在那儿。你是我的同类，我们团队的一员。所以是的，我也觉得，是的，我在这里支持你。而且[叹气]，这就是为什么这个病例如此艰难，因为我觉得我辜负了她100%。
Coming up, the failures in Clara's surgery and where those lead. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来的内容，克拉拉手术中的失败以及那些导致的后果。一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show-- "Chicago Hope." We're hearing a story from the new season of The Retrievals podcast. Susan Burton takes up where she left off.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“芝加哥的希望”。我们正在听《取回者》播客新一季的故事。苏珊·伯顿从上次结束的地方继续。
When Mindy arrives, Clara is still being prepped for surgery. She's flat on her back in the OR, which is obviously not where she wanted to be. The L&D operating rooms at UIC are relatively small, out of another era. Mint green tiles on the walls, like you're stepping into the showers at a YWCA. Harsh light.
当明迪到达时，克拉拉仍在为手术做准备。她平躺在手术室里，这显然不是她想待的地方。UIC的劳产科手术室相对较小，像是另一个时代的产物。墙上贴着薄荷绿的瓷砖，就像走进YWCA的淋浴间一样。刺眼的灯光。
But Clara is calm. We see her now through Mindy's viewfinder, her eyes closed, the expression on her face. My god, it's the embodiment of a word whose use is rarely earned-- beatific.
但克拉拉很冷静。我们现在通过明迪的取景器看着她，她闭着眼睛，脸上的表情。天哪，这是一个罕用的词的化身——充满神圣感。
And I took pictures of everything. I took pictures of Clay and her holding hands. I took pictures of the teams waiting, two different teams for two different babies, pictures of anesthesia working. I like to take pictures of people there because we never get to do that because of privacy laws. So for them to know that I'm on their team, it's almost like, here's a picture of you actually in a case.
我拍下了一切。我拍了克莱和她牵手的照片。我拍了团队等待的照片，两个不同宝宝的两个不同团队，拍了麻醉工作的照片。我喜欢拍在那儿的人的照片，因为因为隐私法我们从没机会做。所以让他们知道我站在他们这边，就像是，这是一张你在手术中的照片。
Surgery's getting closer now. There are poles on either side of Clara's bed, and soon a giant piece of medical paper will be stretched between the poles, blocking Clara's view of her abdomen. This paper is called the drape, and it both protects the surgical field from contamination and protects the patient from the sight of her open body.
手术越来越近了。克拉拉床的两边都有杆子，很快一大块医疗用纸就会在杆子之间拉开，挡住克拉拉看她腹部的视线。这张纸叫手术巾，它既保护手术区域免受污染，又保护病人免受看自己身体裸露的惊吓。
The anesthesiologist has added more drugs to Clara's epidural, making it strong enough to get her through the surgery. Now the doctors need to test to see if the anesthesia is working. Tight on the skin test, it's so weirdly basic-- the anesthesiologist poking Clara with a broken tongue depressor. Another doctor does something more severe-- clamping Clara's belly hard with a surgical instrument. Clara feels none of it. And that means they're ready to go.
麻醉师在克拉拉的硬膜外麻醉里加了更多的药，强度足以让她度过手术。现在医生需要测试麻醉是否起作用。特写皮肤测试，它真的很基本，太奇怪了——麻醉师用一根折断的压舌板戳克拉拉。另一位医生做了更严重的动作——用手术器械用力夹克拉拉的肚子。克拉拉完全没感觉。这意味着他们准备开始了。
There's a decision to make about the C-section, how much of this procedure to show. Like Mindy said, how graphic are we doing? We're not going for gore on this series, for showing open bodies for the kick of it. But we do want visceral, all the meanings of that word.
关于剖腹产有一个决定要下，展示多少这个程序。就像明迪说的，我们要拍到什么程度？我们在这个系列中不是为了追求血腥，不是为了为了刺激而展示敞开的身体。但我们确实想要内脏的，那个词的所有含义。
Viscera, literally, that's what's inside a patient's abdomen. But also how that word is applied to art. Art that's visceral-- it's of the body, it attends to the body. Hopefully, it makes you feel something in your body. A visceral aesthetic, muscular, close to the bone. Raw but not sensational, not shying away.
内脏，字面上看，这就是病人腹部里的东西。但也包括这个词如何应用于艺术。内脏的艺术——它是身体的，它关注身体。希望它能让你在身体里感受到什么。一种内脏的美学，肌肉发达，接近骨骼。原始但不耸人听闻，不避讳。
OK, enough self-regard, enough theory. What does this mean in practice? Now the surgeon calls out, incision, and then cuts into Clara's abdomen, just above the pubic bone. We're not seeing the scalpel in her flesh, OK, but just know that this kind of cut is called a bikini incision. Bikini sounds tiny, but this cut is big. Once Clara's abdomen is open, the surgeon needs to reach the uterus.
好了，自恋够了，理论够了。在实践中这意味着什么？现在外科医生叫道，切口，然后切开克拉拉的腹部，就在耻骨上方。我们没看到手术刀切入她的肉里，好的，但只要知道这种切口叫比基尼切口。比基尼听起来很小，但这个切口很大。一旦克拉拉的腹部打开，外科医生需要到达子宫。
The uterus is behind a pair of muscles. Now we see, actually see, the surgeon and the OB resident position themselves on either side of Clara and pull. These two women in scrubs pull so hard to separate this muscle that their bodies lean back, like in tug of war. This is a very physical surgery. When Clara is a nurse in a C-section, she either covers her eyes or looks away for this part.
子宫在一对肌肉后面。现在我们看到，实际看到，外科医生和产科住院医生站在克拉拉的两侧拉。这两位穿着刷手服的女性拉得如此用力以至于要分开这块肌肉，她们的身体向后倾斜，就像在拔河。这是一个非常物理的手术。当克拉拉作为护士参与剖腹产时，她要么遮住眼睛，要么在那部分移开视线。
But of course, today Clara is the patient. We go behind the drape now, tight on her face, but something's different, radically different. It was just moments ago that she was beatific, but now her mouth is tight.
但当然，今天克拉拉是病人。我们现在走到手术巾后面，紧贴她的脸，但有些东西不同了，彻底的不同了。就在刚才她还充满神圣感，但现在她的嘴唇紧绷。
I just remember, all of a sudden just being like, oh my god, I don't feel good, you know?
我只记得，突然间就觉得，噢天哪，我不舒服，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And I don't know, I assumed I was just panicking. I assumed that I just needed to relax a little bit.
我不知道，我以为我只是在恐慌。我以为我只是需要放松一点。
A few years earlier, Clara had had a panic attack during another surgery at UIC, an eye surgery, cataracts, weird to have them at such a young age. In the surgery, a different kind of paper drape had been unfolded over Clara's whole body, like a death shroud, so that she was entirely covered in blue paper except for a hole over one eye.
几年前，克拉拉在UIC的另一次手术中经历过一次惊恐发作，眼科手术，白内障，这么年轻得白内障很奇怪。在那次手术中，另一张纸巾盖在克拉拉全身，像裹尸布一样，让她整个人被蓝纸覆盖，除了眼睛上的一个洞。
And then she'd heard the doctor say, you need to give her something else, she's hyperventilating. All through her pregnancy, she'd been worried that if she needed a C-section, she would have a panic attack again.
然后她听到医生说，你需要给她点别的，她过度换气了。整个孕期，她一直担心如果需要剖腹产，她会再次惊恐发作。
And so I had spoken with Dr. Nixon about strategies for how to deal with that if I panic.
所以我曾和尼克松医生讨论过如果我惊恐该怎么办的策略。
Yeah.
是的。
And we talked about the different medicines they can give, and that sometimes in that case, nitrous oxide is a really nice, you know, just breath the gas for a little bit. 'Cause they don't last that long. So maybe you can just breathe the gas for a minute or so. And it'll pass, and then you'll be fine, you know?
我们讨论了他们能给的不同药物，有时在这种情况下，一氧化二氮是一个非常好的选择，你知道，就是吸入气体一会儿。因为它们持续时间不长。所以也许你可以吸气一分钟左右。它会过去，然后你就会好的，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So I asked, can I just have some gas or something? And he put the mask on. And it just was getting worse. And I remember feeling very nauseous and just saying that I wasn't OK. And then everything was really fuzzy and hazy. And I am not, I guess, thankfully, able to necessarily recall it in as much detail as I could at first. But it was an unfathomable amount of pain. And I remember begging them to stop.
所以我问，我能吸点气或者什么的吗？他戴上了面具。但这反而更糟了。我记得感到非常恶心，只是说我不行了。然后一切都变得非常模糊。我想，幸运的是，我可能无法像开始时那样详细地回忆起来。但这是一种无法想象的痛苦。我记得恳求他们停下。
And it wasn't until she just kept begging like, please, please, please. And one of the attendings, she looked at me and told me to tell her that it was OK. She told me to tell her partner, please tell him it's OK. So at that moment, I was no longer a friend or an advocate. I was more like a staff member being told by the doctor, it's fine.
直到她一直恳求说，求求你，求求你，求求你。其中一位主治医生看着我，告诉我要告诉她一切都会好的。她让我告诉她的伴侣，请告诉他没事的。所以在那一刻，我不再是朋友或拥护者。我更像是一个被医生告知一切正常的工作人员。
So I remember telling Clay, like, Clay this is normal. This sometimes happens. And Clay, I remember his body language was very like, yeah, OK, I hear you, but don't talk to me. And I remember being like, oh my gosh. Because he was so stressed out.
所以我记得告诉克莱，嘿，克莱这是正常的。这有时会发生。我记得克莱的肢体语言非常像，是的，好吧，我听到了，但别跟我说话。我记得我当时想，噢天哪。因为他压力太大了。
That's one thing I regret the most, that that provider looked at me and said, tell them it's OK, and that I did what she told me to, knowing that it wasn't OK. I think that's one of my biggest things that I replay over and over again, that I didn't say, it's not OK. Can we stop?
这是我最后悔的一件事，那个医护人员看着我说，告诉他们没事的，而我照她说的做了，明明知道事实并非如此。我想这是我一遍又一遍重复的最重要的事情之一，我没说，情况不对。我们能停下吗？
Clara's anesthesia is not working. She is now in the middle of major abdominal surgery, and she can feel that surgery. Clara knew this could happen. She had seen this happen. Intraoperative pain during cesarean-- healthcare providers know about it. Patients don't.
克拉拉的麻醉没有起作用。她现在正处于大型腹部手术的中间，她能感觉到那个手术。克拉拉知道这可能会发生。她见过这种情况。剖腹产期间术中疼痛——医护人员都知道。病人不知道。
When Clara herself first started working on L&D, and patients in labor would tell her, for my last baby, I had a C-section, and I felt everything, Clara would think to herself, that can't be true, there's no way. Who would do that? And then she saw it happen. And now it is happening to her.
当克拉拉刚开始在劳产科工作时，分娩的病人告诉她，生上一个孩子时，我剖腹产了，我感觉到了所有的一切，克拉拉会对自己想，那不可能，没那种事。谁会那样做？然后她看到了这种情况。现在它发生在自己身上。
Visceral, that key word, what Clara is feeling is visceral pain, meaning pain that originates inside her abdomen. When the doctors did the skin test, Clara didn't feel it, right? She was numb. But sometimes a cesarean patient is numb when you test her skin. And when you open her up, you find she's not. There are a lot of reasons for this, but in the moment, the reason for the pain doesn't totally matter. What matters is that you treat it.
内脏，那个关键的词，克拉拉感到的是内脏痛，意思是起源于她腹部深处的疼痛。当医生做皮肤测试时，克拉拉没感觉，对吧？她麻木了。但有时剖腹产病人测试皮肤时麻木。当你打开她时，发现并没有。这有很多原因，但在那一刻，疼痛的原因并不重要。重要的是你治疗它。
The babies, we missed the delivery, but we see them now at the edge of the room in newborn warmers. And we understand they are healthy, that they are OK. But Clara is not. We see Clara punching the drape, as if trying to hit the OBs. What are the OBs doing on the other side of the drape? What are they understanding? What are they feeling? Why are they ordering Mindy to tell Clara's husband everything is all right?
宝宝们，我们错过了分娩，但我们现在在房间边缘的新生儿保温箱里看到了他们。我们明白他们很健康，他们没事。但克拉拉不是。我们看到克拉拉击打手术巾，好像试图打那些产科医生。产科医生在手术巾的另一边在做什么？他们理解什么？他们感觉什么？为什么他们命令明迪告诉克拉拉的丈夫一切正常？
We don't know the answers to these questions yet. We're on the side of the drape with Clara and the anesthesiologist, who's giving her supplemental drugs-- fentanyl, ketamine. Is he doing the right thing, giving her those drugs? We don't know this yet, either. But the feeling we convey now is that something is wrong, very wrong.
我们还不知道这些问题的答案。我们和克拉拉及麻醉师在手术巾的这一边，他正在给她补充药物——芬太尼、氯胺酮。他在做正确的事情吗，给她那些药？我们也不知道。但我们现在传递的感觉是有些不对劲，非常不对劲。
What's going on inside for Clara is that all these drugs have her hallucinating. Is this the kind of show where we do a magical realism thing of inhabiting her consciousness? I mean, it could be, yes, why not use it this way? Why not use it to show what Clara is seeing?
克拉拉内部发生的事情是所有这些药物让她产生了幻觉。这是那种我们会做那种沉浸在意识里的魔幻现实主义的事情吗？我的意思是，可以的，是的，为什么不这样用呢？为什么不用它来展示克拉拉正在看到的东西？
A story I heard-- I'll say this fast-- a mother is given ketamine during her C-section. Her baby is born and the nurse brings her the baby. And the patient says, this is a lovely baby, but this is not my baby. My baby does not have two heads. I heard this story from a doctor. It happened while she was still a resident.
我听过的一个故事——我会快点说——一个母亲在剖腹产时被注射了氯胺酮。她的宝宝出生了，护士把宝宝拿给她。病人说，这是一个可爱的宝宝，但这不是我的宝宝。我的宝宝没有两个头。我从一个医生那里听到的这个故事。那是在她还是住院医生时发生的。
And she told me that after that woman, she never used ketamine for a cesarean patient again. What Clara is seeing, we see now, colors and shapes. If you're a certain kind of person, you might be fine looking at an open abdomen but freaked out looking at hallucinations. Clara feels unable to communicate.
她告诉我，在那位妇女之后，她再也没给剖腹产病人用过氯胺酮。克拉拉正在看到的东西，我们现在看到了，色彩和形状。如果你是某种类型的人，你看敞开的腹部可能没事，但看幻觉会吓坏。克拉拉觉得无法沟通。
She was just so slurry, like please, please stop. No, no, no. She sounded like she was out of her body at that point. And I almost started thinking like, I know she's had issues with post-traumatic stress type issues. So I'm like, maybe this is not pain thing. Maybe it's a psychological thing.
她说话非常含糊，就像求求你，求求你停下。不，不，不。她听起来在那一刻灵魂出窍了。我差点开始想，我知道她有创伤后应激障碍的问题。所以我心想，也许这不是疼痛问题。也许是心理问题。
And this happens a lot where patients complain of pain and we brush it off as, she's anxious. It's just pressure. But it wasn't. Because she would feel anytime they touched or did the cautery. Like, she would say the burning, she could feel the burning.
这种情况经常发生，病人们抱怨疼痛，我们却以她很焦虑。只是压力。打发掉。但并不是。因为她能感觉到他们触摸或使用电灼时的任何感觉。就像，她说烧灼，她能感觉到烧灼。
The cautery instrument is called the Bovie. It stanches bleeding. And the red hot pain of it is something Clara remembers precisely. Something that years later, would wake her up in the middle of the night. The sear of that instrument, Clara, exclaiming, ow, and a doctor saying, we'll move to the other side. What?
电灼器械叫博维（Bovie）。它止血。那种红热的疼痛是克拉拉准确记得的。多年后，会在深夜把她惊醒的事情。那种器械的灼烧，克拉拉惊呼，哎哟，医生说，我们移到另一边。什么？
There's still a lot of surgery left after the delivery. And now we're going to see a part I know some people might not want to see. Brace for it. I'm giving you the warning. The doctor is lifting Clara's uterus out of her body and resting it on her abdomen. It's like a giant, shiny Easter egg. The uterus has been exteriorized. That's what this is called.
分娩后手术还有很多。现在我们要看一部分我知道有些人可能不想看的内容。做好准备。我给你预警。医生正把克拉拉的子宫从她体内拿出来，放在她的腹部上。它就像一个巨大的、闪亮的复活节彩蛋。子宫被外翻了。这就是它的名称。
And the reason we're seeing this is-- please remember that Clara can feel this, can feel her organ being lifted out of her body. Oh, and at some point during all of this, Clara starts throwing up. Now, the surgeon sticks a good portion of her forearm into Clara's body. What we see in the shot is just the arm disappearing into the abdomen. She's using a pad of gauze to check for internal bleeding.
我们看到这个的原因是——请记住克拉拉能感觉到这个，能感觉到她的器官被提到了体外。噢，而且在这一切的某个时候，克拉拉开始呕吐。现在，外科医生把她前臂的大部分伸进克拉拉的体内。我们在镜头里看到的就是那条手臂消失在腹部里。她正用一块纱布检查是否有内出血。
Again, the point is, Clara is feeling this. Now we hear her scream, "Why are you doing this? Make it stop." And now we do, as if on her command, we leave the surgery. We need to get out of this OR where bad things are happening and we don't understand why. Outside of the operating room, an obstetric anesthesiologist named Cory is arriving for his 7:00 AM shift.
再说一次，重点是，克拉拉正在感觉到这个。现在我们听到她尖叫，你们为什么要这样做？让它停下。现在我们真的像在她的命令下，离开了手术。我们需要离开这个正在发生坏事且我们不明白原因的手术室。手术室外，一位叫科里的产科麻醉师正赶来他早上7点的班。
Cory, we're not going to meet Cory as a main character. Maybe he's someone who will be developed later in another episode. He's trim and boyishly handsome. We watch as several nurses urge him toward the OR. Cory, you need to get in there now. Cory pushes open the door and enters the room just as the surgeons are putting the final stitches in Clara's skin.
科里，我们不会把科里作为主角来介绍。也许他是以后在另一集中会深入发展的人物。他修长，外表帅气，充满男孩气。我们看着几名护士催促他向手术室走去。科里，你现在需要进去。科里推开门进入房间，正好赶上外科医生在克拉拉的皮肤上缝最后几针。
And then all of a sudden, at some point, it was over. And I just, the first thing I remember is just looking around. And then Cory was there. He's one of the anesthesiologists.
然后突然间，在某个时候，结束了。我记得的第一件事就是环顾四周。然后科里在那儿。他是麻醉师之一。
Yeah.
是的。
And I remember seeing Cory, and he came right by down my face. 'Cause I was still on the table, but all the drapes, everything was gone and done. And Cory was right there. And I remember, I was just like, oh, Cory, you'll help me. I was just like, oh, you'll help me.
我记得看到科里，他来到我的脸边。因为我还在台上，但所有的手术巾，一切都拆掉结束了。科里就在那儿。我记得，我当时就像，噢，科里，你会帮我的。我当时就像，噢，你会帮我的。
Cory, Clara knows him, trusts him, unlike the other anesthesiologist. She had no idea who that guy was. We see some relief in Clara's face and we see Cory holding back tears. And even though there's no resolution or total explanation, at least we know that Clara is being cared for. Cory wheels Clara to the recovery room, the PACU, and as soon as she's settled, Cory goes down the hall and calls his boss-- Heather.
科里，克拉拉认识他，信任他，不像那个别的麻醉师。她根本不知道那个家伙是谁。我们在克拉拉的脸上看到了一些解脱，我们看到科里忍着泪水。尽管没有解决办法或完全的解释，至少我们知道克拉拉得到了照顾。科里把克拉拉推到恢复室，PACU，她一安顿下来，科里就沿着走廊给他的老板打电话——希瑟。
He calls me and he's like, Heather, something happened. And I was like, OK. What's going on?
他打给我说，希瑟，出事了。我说，好的。怎么了？
Heather was at home. She'd been at the hospital so long the night before that she got the day off. Cory told her about Clara.
希瑟在家。她前一晚在医院待了太久，所以那天休息。科里告诉了她克拉拉的事。
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. That just can't be. And I was like, Cory, what happened? He's like, I don't even know. And I just felt-- I felt horrible. I felt like I shouldn't have left the hospital, that I should have just stayed until she was safely taken care, that she had delivered, that I had let her down in that. And then I got mad. And then I got really mad.
噢天哪，不不不不不，这不可能。我说，科里，发生了什么？他说，我甚至不知道。我只是感到——我感到很可怕。我觉得我不该离开医院，我本该留在那里直到她安全地被照顾好，她已经分娩了，我在这点上辜负了她。然后我生气了。然后我真的非常生气。
Heather is mad because she's in charge here. And she's an anesthesiologist. The thing the anesthesiologist is in the room to do is manage pain. Cutting someone's body open and then operating when they can feel it, that is not supposed to happen. That's something from history or from war.
希瑟很生气，因为她是这里的负责人。她是麻醉师。麻醉师在房间里要做的就是管理疼痛。把人的身体打开，然后在她能感觉到的时候手术，这不应该发生。那是历史或战争中的事。
But in the United States, it happens 100,000 times a year. That's the best estimate of how many patients have significant pain during cesarean. Not all of these patients feel the exact same intensity of pain, or at the same parts of the surgery, or for the same length of time, but the pain they feel is significant. Most people don't know about this. Until recently, I didn't.
但在美国，它每年发生10万次。这是关于有多少病人在剖腹产期间感到剧烈疼痛的最佳估计。并非所有这些病人都感到相同强度的疼痛，或者在手术的相同部分，或相同的时间长度，但他们感到的疼痛是显着的。大多数人不知道这一点。直到最近，我也不知道。
I learned of it from listeners to season one of this podcast. It doesn't matter if you haven't heard season one. The details are less important than the common experience it described-- pain a doctor didn't listen to, pain a doctor didn't adequately treat. That experience resonated with many listeners, and hundreds of them, mostly women, began writing to me with their own stories.
我是从这个播客第一季的听众那里得知的。你没听过第一季也没关系。细节不如它描述的共同经历重要——医生不听的疼痛，医生没有充分治疗的疼痛。那种经历引起了许多听众的共鸣，数百人，主要是女性，开始写信给我，分享她们自己的故事。
One afternoon, I opened a note that was unlike any I'd received so far. "I had a C-section," the email began, "where anesthesia was not properly administered. I remember telling them I could feel the cutting, the moving of my organs, the burning, shocking, brutal pain, and being told that wasn't possible and that I would just have to tough it out."
一天下午，我打开了一封和我之前收到的都不一样的信。“我做过剖腹产，”邮件开始说，“当时的麻醉没有正确实施。我记得我告诉他们我能感觉到切割，感觉到器官的移动，感觉到那种灼烧、冲击、残酷的疼痛，却被告知那是不可能的，我只能忍着。”
To me, this listener's experience seemed so out of range that it might be singular. Then I opened two more of these notes. Soon I understood this was a subject that would come up again and again.
对我来说，这位听众的经历显得范围太窄了，可能是个别情况。然后我打开了另外两封这样的信。很快我明白了这是一个会反复出现的主题。
C-sections are the most frequently performed surgery in the world. In the US, there are 1.2 million of them a year. So 100,000 patients a year feeling pain during cesarean, that's 8%. Some people say the rate is even higher. There's no other surgery where this happens, no other major surgery where it would be acceptable for 8% of patients to feel that surgery.
剖腹产是世界上执行频率最高的手术。在美国，每年有120万例。所以每年有10万名病人感到剖腹产时的疼痛，那是8%。有些人说这个比例甚至更高。没有其他手术会出现这种情况，没有其他大型手术是可以接受8%的病人感到手术疼痛的。
8% is a brand new number from a recently completed study. It didn't replace an old number. It's the first number of its kind. Until now, nobody had ever done a study like this, asking thousands of patients in the US and Canada whether they felt pain during their C-sections.
8%是一个来自最近完成的研究的全新数字。它没有取代旧数字。它是同类中的第一个数字。直到现在，从来没有人做过这样的研究，询问美国和加拿大的数千名病人她们在剖腹产时是否感到疼痛。
But now the study has been done by doctors who recognize that this is a problem and that putting a number to it is a step toward solving it. And this is what this story is about. Not just that there's a problem with severe pain, but that people are trying to solve it.
但现在这项研究是由认识到这是一个问题并且给它一个数字是迈向解决的一步的医生完成的。这就是这个故事的内容。不仅是有严重疼痛的问题，而且人们正试图解决它。
As soon as I finished season one of The Retrievals, people began asking me, what are the solutions to fixing this problem in medicine of dismissing women's pain? I was surprised the first time I got this question about solutions. Obviously, I should not have been surprised. But I didn't have a bullet point list. How to shift an entire culture, how to listen to women patients-- these are really complicated issues.
我一完成《取回者》第一季，人们就开始问我，解决医学中忽视女性疼痛这个问题有什么办法？我第一次得到这个关于解决方案的问题时很惊讶。显然，我不应该感到惊讶。但我没有要点列表。如何转变整个文化，如何倾听女性病人的心声——这些都是非常复杂的问题。
And solutions had not been the focus of my reporting. I looked at what went wrong. Exploring what went wrong doesn't automatically translate to solutions on how to make it right. But this question made me curious. Well, what are the solutions? It turned out that a bunch of people interested in pain during cesarean were thinking about the same thing.
解决方案不是我报道的焦点。我着眼于出了什么问题。探索出了什么问题并不能自动转化为如何纠正的解决方案。但这个问题让我很好奇。那么，解决方案是什么？结果发现，一群对剖腹产疼痛感兴趣的人也在思考同样的事情。
So here we go, a case study in solving one of medicine's most persistent problems, listening to women patients and adequately treating their pain, told through the experiences of four women-- Clara, Heather, Mindy, and Susanna, who run up against this problem and take it on, with efforts that touch both individual patients and entire countries. How do they do this? What can they change? And what does it cost them?
所以我们开始吧，一个解决医学最持久问题之一的案例研究，倾听女性病人的心声并充分治疗她们的疼痛，通过四个女性——克拉拉、希瑟、明迪和苏珊娜的经历讲述，她们遇到了这个问题并承担起来，努力触及单个病人甚至整个国家。她们是怎么做的？她们能改变什么？这让她们付出了什么代价？
Back at the hospital, Clara has been moved from the PACU to a bed. It isn't long before she hears from Heather.
回到医院，克拉拉已经从PACU被移到了病房。没过多久她就收到了希瑟的消息。
It was that day. She was really upset too. She was really sorry that it happened.
就是那天。她也非常难过。她对发生这件事感到非常抱歉。
Yeah.
是的。
Because Cory, obviously, yeah, Cory told her. Anyway, and she was really sorry.
因为科里，显然，是的，科里告诉了她。总之，她非常抱歉。
The first time I saw her, she looked at me and she goes, Heather, what the fuck? What the fuck, Heather? And I just went, I'm so sorry. And she was really-- it was hard. She was really, really raw. She was not OK.
我第一次见到她时，她看着我，她说，希瑟，这他妈是怎么回事？这他妈是怎么回事，希瑟？我只是说，我非常抱歉。她真的——这很难。她真的，非常痛苦。她当时不好。
And I said to her, I said, listen, when you're ready, I'd love to just get some information from you. Because I'm going to take this beyond where we are right now. I said, I'm going to make sure that institutionally, this doesn't happen again. And I'm going to make sure that people hear about this and that this can be used for good.
我对她说，我说，听着，当你准备好了，我很想从你那里得到一些信息。因为我打算把它带到我们现在所处的范围之外。我说，我会确保从体制上讲，这种情况不会再发生。我会确保人们听到这件事，它可以被用于好的方面。
She wasn't going to let it go and she was gonna take action. She was gonna do something to prevent this from happening again.
她不会让这件事过去，她会采取行动。她会做些什么来防止这种情况再次发生。
And now we see Clara in her bed, and we follow her gaze out of the window, out of the hospital, down to the street, where we pause for a second over Mindy's minivan, an orange parking ticket on the windshield. And then we continue across the city, arcing back over the same elevated tracks and wide highways we traversed earlier, only now it's dusk instead of dawn.
现在我们看到克拉拉躺在床上，我们随着她的目光看向窗外，离开医院，看向街道，我们在明迪的小货车上停留了一秒钟，挡风玻璃上一张橙色的停车罚单。然后我们继续穿过城市，绕回我们之前走过的同样的那些高架铁轨和宽阔的高速公路，只是现在是黄昏而不是黎明。
And when we get to the lake, we turn around so that we can see the sunset over those magnificent buildings, their windows fiery with the day's last light. And we hold that shot as the music swells and the credits roll.
当我们到达湖边时，我们转过身，这样我们就能看到那些宏伟建筑上的日落，它们的窗户在一天最后的余晖中闪烁。随着音乐的响起和演职员表的滚动，我们保持着那个镜头。
Susan Burton. OK, so that was the opening episode of season two of her podcast, The Retrievals. And I kind of said this at the top of the show. As the story unfolds in later episodes of the podcast, it does this thing that I think almost never happens in a big investigative story. It becomes surprisingly hopeful. Doctors take a look at the problem that Susan is documenting, and then they act the way that you would hope that doctors would act. They take it seriously.
苏珊·伯顿。好的，以上就是她播客第二季的第一集。我刚才在节目开头也说了。随着故事在播客的后续剧集中展开，它做了一件我觉得在大型调查报道中几乎从不发生的事情。它变得出奇地充满希望。医生们审视苏珊记录的问题，然后他们采取了你希望医生会采取的行为方式。他们认真对待。
People step forward to try to change things. One of them is the head of obstetric anesthesia from this first episode, Heather Nixon. I'm going to play you a clip from the second episode so you can hear what I'm talking about. It's interesting. By sheer coincidence, Heather Nixon had been scheduled to give a speech on pain during cesareans at a major medical conference before she saw how the anesthesia in Clara's C-section went wrong.
人们站出来试图改变事情。其中之一就是第一集中产科麻醉的主管，希瑟·尼克松。我将为你播放第二集的一个片段，这样你就能听到我在说什么。很有意思。纯属巧合的是，希瑟·尼克松在看到克拉拉剖腹产时的麻醉情况出错之前，就已经预定要在一次大型医学会议上发表关于剖腹产疼痛的演讲。
And so she had been planning on doing a speech focusing on technical tips. But now she rethought this. She decided to do something much more participatory than a typical medical conference speech. And when the day of the speech came, she began her talk by telling the assembled doctors the story of Clara's cesarean, how Clara felt, what was happening during her surgery, and really what that did to Clara in the aftermath.
所以她原计划做一次专注于技术技巧的演讲。但现在她重新考虑了。她决定做一些比典型的医学会议演讲更具参与性的事情。当演讲当天到来时，她通过向在场的医生讲述克拉拉剖腹产的故事开始她的谈话，克拉拉的感觉，手术中发生的事情，以及那在后果中真正对克拉拉造成了什么。
And then, the action turns, the story turns to one of a number of very insidery, almost behind-the-scenes moments where doctors are trying to be honest with each other and with themselves about their own failures and how to fix them. OK, here's a bit of that.
然后，行动转向，故事转向了一系列非常深入的、几乎是幕后的时刻，医生们试图对彼此和对自己诚实，关于他们自己的失败以及如何修复它们。好的，听听这个。
Usually at a medical conference, people are typing on their laptops or holding their phones up to the screen to take pictures of the slides. This room is still
通常在医学会议上，人们在笔记本电脑上打字，或者拿着手机对着屏幕拍摄幻灯片。这个房间很安静。
So this is a harrowing story. It made me mad. It made me sad. It made me frustrated. And it made me really take a deep dive into what is going on in our country. If you go to Google and you search intraoperative pain for cesarean delivery, you will see horror stories across this country.
所以这是一个令人揪心的故事。它让我生气。它让我难过。它让我沮丧。它让我真正深入研究了我们国家正在发生的事情。如果你去谷歌搜索剖腹产术中疼痛，你会看到全国各地的恐怖故事。
And this is really staggering because nowhere else in anesthesia do we allow this to happen. Nowhere, right? If you have a block that doesn't work for an ortho case, your patient goes to sleep. We don't suffer through it. We don't bite the bullet. We don't ask our patient to just take it.
这真的很令人震惊，因为在麻醉的其他地方，我们不允许这种情况发生。没地方，对吧？如果你有一个脊髓麻醉在骨科手术中不起作用，你的病人就会去睡觉。我们不忍受它。我们不咬牙坚持。我们不要求我们的病人只是忍受它。
So I'm going to ask just this room at this moment, how many people in the last month have had a patient who's had severe intraoperative pain?
所以我现在要问这个房间的每个人，有多少人在上个月有一位经历了严重术中疼痛的病人？
There are hundreds of people in the room. We watch as half of them raise their hands-- half. Heather had asked how many people in the last month had a patient who had severe pain during their C-section, and half of the doctors raised their hands.
房间里有数百人。我们看着他们中的一半举起了手——一半。希瑟问有多少人在上个月有一位在剖腹产期间感到剧痛的病人，一半的医生举起了手。
OK. So this is not rare. We have a group of experts in the room who clearly are experiencing this on a daily basis, and we're just beginning to talk about it.
好的。所以这并不罕见。我们在房间里有一群专家，显然每天都在经历这种情况，而我们才刚刚开始谈论它。
And it's crazy that we're just beginning to talk about it because it's a known problem, Heather says. She ticks through all the different kinds of knowing. There's medical literature. There's litigation. There's doctors' own experiences in the operating room. So what that means is that there's an active kind of not knowing, and that act of not knowing is as much of a problem as the pain itself.
而我们才刚刚开始谈论它真的很疯狂，因为它是一个已知的问题，希瑟说。她列举了所有不同种类的知道。有医学文献。有诉讼。有医生自己在手术室的经历。所以这意味着有一种主动的不知道，而那种不知道的行为与疼痛本身一样是一个问题。
So how do we fix this? How do we think about this? And how do we change what's happening? So why is this happening? All right, I'm going to assume that everyone in this room is passionate about what they do. They love obstetric patients. They're here to learn. They want to do the best. And I'm going to assume that no one gets into medicine to hurt people, OK? We want to help people. So what is the disconnect?
那么我们如何解决这个问题？我们如何思考它？我们如何改变正在发生的事情？那么为什么会发生这种情况？好的，我假设在这个房间里的每个人都对自己所做的事情充满热情。他们热爱产科病人。他们来这里学习。他们想做到最好。而且我假设没有人进入医学是为了伤害别人，好的？我们想帮助别人。那么脱节在哪里？
Heather's put the questions to the group plainly. How willing they'll be to wrestle with them is anyone's guess. She opens the discussion to the room. The first person to speak is a doctor from New York City named Dan.
希瑟向群体明确提出了问题。他们愿意花多大精力去挣扎，谁也说不准。她向房间开放了讨论。第一个发言的人是一位名叫丹的纽约市医生。
When we think about why this happens, I think there is this specter in the back of our heads that says, oh crap, the spinal is not working. If I have to induce general anesthesia, there's a chance, because we all have PTSD, that the pregnant airway is horrific, that I'm going to lose the airway and the mom will die.
当我们思考为什么会发生这种情况时，我想在我们的脑后有一个幽灵，说，噢糟糕，脊髓麻醉不起作用。如果我必须进行全身麻醉，有一个机会，因为我们都有创伤后应激障碍，怀孕的气道是可怕的，我会失去气道，妈妈会死。
And I think that is what is-- I'm gonna say it, that is a fear of mine, that I will lose the airway. And then they'll be like, well, yeah, she was uncomfortable, but maybe you could have muscled through and at least she'd be alive. And so that is the balance that I find when I'm dealing with this in the operating room. And I don't know if other people have had that same discussion in their head.
我想这就是——我会说出来，这是一个我的恐惧，我会失去气道。然后他们会说，好吧，是的，她不舒服，但也许你可以硬撑过去，至少她还活着。所以这就是我在手术室处理这个问题时发现的平衡。我不知道其他人是否在脑海中有过同样的讨论。
No warm up. No superficial comments before the room really gets going. Dan goes deep straight away. Sometimes I'm scared, he's saying. I'm scared of the biggest thing of all. And in that situation, it seems like the better choice is pain. Heather meets Dan's vulnerability with some of her own.
没有热身。在房间真正开始之前没有肤浅的评论。丹直接深入。有时我很害怕，他说。我害怕最大的事情。在这种情况下，似乎更好的选择是疼痛。希瑟用她自己的一些脆弱满足了丹的脆弱。
So I think that that's a wonderful point. We were taught, since fellowship, since I was a baby, I was taught, don't take on the airway. Pregnant is the big bad wolf. Stay away from it. This is how moms die. You'll never recover. The family will never recover. And so, especially towards the end of a case, you might be like, eh, do I really need to?
所以我认为这是一个很棒的观点。我们被教导过，从研究员开始，从我还是个婴儿开始，我就被教导，不要动气道。怀孕是大坏蛋。远离它。这就是妈妈们死亡的方式。你永远不会恢复。家庭永远不会恢复。所以，特别是在一个病例接近尾声时，你可能会想，呃，我真的需要吗？
This is the gray area that's ugly and it doesn't feel good. And at the end of the day, I don't feel satisfied with my job because maybe I did the right thing, maybe I didn't. And I'm honest enough to admit it. I've been in that situation several times where I've looked at this and been like, do I really want to do this? Even when the patient maybe had some discomfort.
这是丑陋的灰色地带，感觉不好。最终，我对我的工作不满意，因为也许我做了正确的事，也许我没有。而且我很诚实，敢于承认它。我好几次处于那种情况，我看着这个，心里想，我真的想做这个吗？即使病人也许有一些不适。
From the stage, Heather sees one of the women she trained with in fellowship, giving her a look like, same. People start lining up behind the mics. There's a doctor who practices in New Jersey.
在台上，希瑟看到了她在研究员期间培训过的一位女性，给了她一个看起来像，我也是的表情。人们开始在麦克风后面排队。有一位在纽泽西执业的医生。
So that for me, it's not just about, oh, the patient's comfortable or she's just exaggerating. It's sometimes that fear that if I do get into a general anesthesia, no one knows how to help me.
所以对我来说，这不仅是关于，噢，病人很舒服或者她只是夸大其词。有时是担心，如果我确实进行全身麻醉，没人知道怎么帮我。
And there's Zevy.
还有泽维。
I'm Zevy. I'm also from New York City. I actually really appreciate your point about saying the quiet part out loud, where we're here--
我是泽维。我也来自纽约市。我真的很感激你关于把安静的部分大声说出来的观点，我们在这里——
The part that spinals and epidurals can fail. When do you tell the patient this thing that you know to be true, but that may sound so alarming to them? These things fail. Wait, what? You're telling me this now?
脊髓麻醉和硬膜外麻醉会失败的部分。你什么时候告诉病人这个你知道是真实的事情，但听起来可能对她们非常惊人？这些事情会失败。等一下，什么？你现在才告诉我这个？
I was wondering how many people actually say that in the pre-op, discuss that spinals and epidurals actually fail. And if they do fail, we test for it. And we have options to fix it beforehand, even during your consent process.
我想知道有多少人在术前真正说了，讨论了脊髓麻醉和硬膜外麻醉确实会失败。如果它们确实失败了，我们进行测试。而且我们在术前，甚至在你的知情同意过程中就有选项来修复它。
I'm Andi. I'm from Stanford. I just wanted to share one of my techniques. Sometimes I either have a patient where maybe there's a language barrier, they're exhausted, they're really scared, and I think my block is working because my block is going to work, but to take my ego out of it--
我是安迪。我来自斯坦福。我只是想分享我的一个技巧。有时我有一个病人，也许有语言障碍，她们筋疲力尽，她们真的很害怕，而且我觉得我的麻醉起作用了，因为我的麻醉会起作用，但要把我的自我从中拿出来——
We are tight on Andi's face so that you can see she's being self-deprecating, not cocky, gently reminding the group to be alert to their own hubris. Doctors continue to come forward, asking questions, offering tips, letting out frustrations.
我们紧贴安迪的脸，这样你就能看到她是自嘲，而不是傲慢，温柔地提醒大家注意自己的自大。医生们继续走上前，提出问题，提供建议，释放挫败感。
Intraoperatively, I think that the pain versus pressure question is a trope that I really hate in our specialty.
术中，我认为疼痛与压力的问题是我们专业中我真的很讨厌的一个比喻。
But to sort of give the patient the feeling of, don't worry your pretty little head about this, it's fine, [LAUGHS] that is horrible. It is horrible to not feel listened to. And so I think we all have to--
但要给病人一种感觉，别担心，亲爱的，没事的，[笑]那是可怕的。不被倾听是可怕的。所以我觉得我们都必须——
Heather had been worried that there would come a moment like, OK, it's great we're talking about this, but what do we do? Where's the algorithm we follow if a patient is in severe pain? She wasn't sending anyone off with an algorithm to follow because that algorithm didn't exist.
希瑟一直担心会出现那样的一刻，好的，我们谈论这个很好，但我们做什么？如果病人感到剧烈疼痛，我们遵循的算法在哪里？她没有让任何人带着要遵循的算法离开，因为那个算法不存在。
So just a quick thought--
所以只是一个快速想法——
And it's clear that the audience is eager to come up with solutions.
而且很明显，听众渴望提出解决方案。
Um, I do have a way--
嗯，我确实有一种方式——
There's a lot of crowdsourcing, Heather and others talking about everything from specific doses of medicine to styles of communication. Heather has scoured the medical literature for relevant research on this. But for today, the goal is not to settle on a fix. This is steps to solve a problem. Step one-- talk about the problem. That was what Heather wanted, and apparently it was what the room had wanted too.
有很多众包，希瑟和其他人谈论从特定的药物剂量到沟通风格的一切。希瑟已经在医学文献中搜寻了关于此的相关研究。但今天，目标不是定下一个修复方案。这是解决问题的步骤。第一步——谈论这个问题。那是希瑟想要的，显然也是房间里想要的。
Susan Burton. From there, through the later episodes of this podcast, we hear doctors try to put in place procedures to fix this problem and to change the culture in their operating rooms. It's really something. And one of the key people who makes this happen is somebody who's not even a doctor. That's a whole story in itself. So The Retrievals Season Two. There are four episodes in all from Serial and The New York Times. You can get it wherever you get your podcasts.
苏珊·伯顿。从那里，通过这个播客的后续剧集，我们听到医生试图实施程序来解决这个问题并改变他们手术室里的文化。这真的很棒。而促成这一切的关键人物之一甚至不是医生。这本身就是一个完整的故事。所以《取回者》第二季。总共有四集，来自Serial和《纽约时报》。你可以在任何获取播客的地方获得它。
So what you heard today on our show, The Retrievals Season Two, was hosted, written, and reported by Susan Burton, produced by Julie Snyder and Ben Phelan. It was edited by Julie Snyder, with additional editing by Laura Starcheski and Jessica Weisberg and engineered by Phoebe Wang, with original music by Dan Powell, Fritz Myers, and Nick Thornburn.
所以今天你们在我们的节目中听到的，《取回者》第二季，由苏珊·伯顿主持、撰写和报道，朱莉·斯奈德和本·菲兰制作。由朱莉·斯奈德编辑，劳拉·斯塔切斯基和杰西卡·韦斯伯格协助编辑，菲比·王工程，原创音乐由丹·鲍威尔、弗里茨·迈尔斯和尼克·索恩伯恩创作。
Special thanks to Elizabeth Livingston, Blair Arthur, Vanessa Lehner, Rachel Roberts, Lynn Holland, Carolina Mendoza, Clara Hochhauser, and Jaime Daly. Our This American Life episode was put together by Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, and Angela Gervasi. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. If you would like to get lots of bonus content and help us keep our show going, you can become a life partner. Subscribe to our program by going to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
特别感谢伊丽莎白·利文斯顿、布莱尔·亚瑟、瓦内萨·莱纳、雷切尔·罗伯茨、林恩·霍兰、卡罗琳娜·门多萨、克拉拉·霍克豪瑟和杰米·戴利。我们的《美国生活》剧集由米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森和安吉拉·格瓦西整理。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。如果你想获得大量的奖励内容并帮助我们维持节目，你可以成为生活伴侣。通过前往thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners订阅我们的节目。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He remembers his first monthly paycheck working at a public radio station. I guess it was a long time ago.
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他记得他在公共广播电台工作时的第一份月薪。我猜那是很久以前的事了。
$200. And I was like, [GASPS], that's a lot of money.
200美元。我当时就像，[喘息]，这可是很多钱。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。